Mikey Anderson and Drew dowy played together
for the last couple of years they their number
one deep Pair by Park they've been a little leaky
lately maybe letting him get a break here tonight
Spence kicks it back into the corner and this
one's turned over inside the games line back
towards the in Ted in front by Sherry and go made
the stop there can't a 41 goal score last season
G ring towards that bounces off of B out oh just
wide by runstrom and he bumped into baseski in
the [Applause] process Calvin Dean at Center
snaps it near side Celli dumps it in Calvin
direct traffic around the boards s back around by
Hegel and goes Celli heavily back towards the LA
net and there's Matt Roy keeping things to the
outside they tried to get in a CIT on the Fly
that one was cut off and held in by Celli now it's
Hegel and angle TS back on Ro his shot right on
and Talbot makes the Stop and there's no rebound
now the puckets free there is Watson kicks it
around to The Far Side in front for p can't get
a shot away Way B and it's pushed wide by kerov
centering attempt never got through and now it's
Hegel back up the ice with Celli and asimon in the
line Celli and asimon his shot save by Thomas and
the rebound to the corner does his job looks it
down now back the way for La Kar drops off the
king try to set up here's doy doy looks shoots
right on and bosi makes the save headman up the
boards gathered by chernack chernak looking for
options keeps it hangs on ER kernack in C and
it is steed in behind the LA net near Point J
know to Spence GF sharp angled shot and that's
kick the side by Basi just as the power play
comes to an end heel gets a little help now he's
stripped by k kick Sav by baseli back pass picked
off and controlled by Celli and Hegel lately he
keeps going over the net I know he's trying to
go for the top shelf and some of them get turns
the puck over there's another lead pass looking
for COV and gabov has stepped up on him now it's
more more in with a shot and that caught a piece
to the crossbar and goes up and out of play later
or been a second later on that play excuse me the
puck would have risen right up over top of him and
gone into the slot that was that was really alert
there well done and as a result a over the shot
Reb and to to make another save on liberg nice
job along the wall and Mikey ASA ends up getting
a really good scoring chance because of [Music] it
here's Val v b a little time well it's me got on
side gives it up to more drops it out to Spence
Spence Around the Net s is it they score a great
play by Jordan Spence puts it out for philli Deno
and it's one- nothing Kings but they make this one
count they get some good motion and a line chain
top of your screen see Philip do know is fresh
he comes right off the right off the bench and
they're able to move the puck around the outside
and get it into the middle excuse me it was Spence
that came out and he gets it to Deno it looks
like everybody's covered and there's bodies in
front for the lightning as Spence is going around
Nick Paul is looking at the puck but they don't
tie up and that pass attempt back to the point
it's picked off by Moore MO is got an assist to
the goal here's via slap pass across finds the
moving Target Roy scores Kevin via to Mad Roy
and he did not miss and it is two nothing La he
goes to the bench afterwards he tries to force
it back to the point it's a smart read by Moore
now kucherov is changing so it's now a five on
four a quick attack here by Los Angeles so that
means Roy is well aware that he's able to move
in from the point top right of your screen you
can see part of the line change there for the
lightning doesn't get there in time it allows
the defenseman to come in from the point makes
a nice move into the middle and an even better
shot that one looked like it went over the they
play in straight lines they had saw goal tending
just like in this game and they're up two zip face
off win pulled back to Dahan Dahan to the corner
got a center it out in front to is down and he
has got it and ason certainly isn't either and
lightning here thinking hey we had a chance this
Puck looked like it was loose Celli took a whack
at it Ison comes in and Celli starts celebrating
because he thinks it's in it was in fact in but
the whistle had already gone there goes a go t
he sits on it but is it is it free it is look
at Celli Celli is looking right down between
his pads and for Celli's mind this is going to be
close they have a decent argument here watch here
at the very end watch how the skate catches on
the pad and pulls his Pad away now he also has
to sit down on purpose because now the puck is
there thir the wing to play there was go Ender
interference therefore the call is overturn we
have no goal Bo back and forth with Celli up top
to Hond need a shot here there's one wide Rebound
in front P side save by tala to the rebound
cleared and the Kings step out again leier
is Jackson turns the puck over back in the
way they come cing pass across they score
aery pass knocked in and the lightning on
the board Tyler M makes it 2-1 back check
in the neutral zone right there top of your
screen he's the one that turns the play around
so fittingly he should be the recipient of a
really good pass and hard work by asimon ason
always keeps the feet moving and he's good at
protecting the puck then he puts it into
the scoring area M's timing is great the
shot is even better and now they're finally
within one third goal of the season in for
Tyler M I think he's been very visible tonight
here's M the goal score in this period for the
lightning perix with a headman
pass up to Hegel Hegel Cuts in
stays with it St Brandon hega
his time to [Music] [Applause]
game great set of hands by Brandon Hegel
and he had to fight his way with the puck
through traffic how about that little move
that was simply outstanding spinning around
grundstrom will come across on him and thinks
he's got him yeah I got this Puck that is a
beautiful little move at high speed while he's
spinning from forwards to backwards controlling
it nobody knocks him down and he finds away
just Wills this one into the back of the net
after a nice little pouette in a slot it's two
do pck cam talet gave it up now the Kings come
back across the line with numbers it is a shot
oh there a hard POS and a hard snapshot there
by Lewis but on this last shift end to end
action a couple of good chances and that one
clanked works it into the corner he's bear
hugg there by DUIs e go great work gets it
a perect per he's in go an overtime
winner from Nick [Music] [Applause]
permit Brandon Hegel does a heck of a job here
he comes back on the back check and then look at
him just a foot race with Spence but he stops
and keeps it under control and keeps spinning
around and keeps it under some kind of control
when he's being two onone got allows perix to
make a move and get a little inside position and
then perix does a heck of a job protect the puck
anticipate the side swipe by Trevor Moore stays
away from it forehand backhand game winner and
once again Brandon Hegel in on the overtime
goal he's been in on all three they've gotten
this season at what a moment for Nick perck and
what a rally for the Tampa Bay Lightning tonight